I'm now going to wit mathematicians all
you want to generalize right so I'm
going to stop talking you know this is
one what it was some other number I have
10 you might write 7 or whatever let's
give it a name let's call this side a no
way that's the strong one
if I take any that's the long side on
the short side ok whatever that ratio is
this should be equal to now what's
happening what's happening this is
actually equal to the reason why it's
similar but the similar rectangles give
you this ratio like I know we're used to
think about in triangles right the
corresponding sides and similar
triangles we're in the same ratio right
well it works for any shape you like
right it could be similar rectangles is
for simple Pentagon's or anything okay
you've got this similarity happening in
here okay now when we took this ratio
with david this special name by Sir how
can I work with this I can work with
this alright if I say look Phi is equal
to this ratio everything or just
consider this time from there it's just
this just look at him
a plus B or na I can simplify that I can
simplify that that's um a over a plus B
over a right yeah well that's that's one
Avery right yeah B over a I could leave
it like that but I can write it in terms
of this ratio that I know it's not the
ratio it's the it's the reciprocal of
the ratio right I want to hear of eight
them to be over right so it's actually 1
over 5 you're following how do I go from
here from here to here okay I want you
to look carefully right and this is in
some ways you know right this way what
makes the golden ratio like the reason
why we got these similar rectangles in
here right it's because it means the
ratio of two numbers and I'm calling
them I'll call Amy
equals the ratio of the sum of those two
numbers are some of those two numbers
and the larger number okay so look the
ratio between two numbers is the same as
the ratio between the sum of those two
numbers and the larger number that's
that's where I'm getting this
relationship okay it's a great question
thank you for asking you know I said
that all of this is equal to a or b
right this is all equal to this whole
thing is equal fine now I know you're
not used to looking at equations like
this and having to solve them but it's
actually an equation you know and you're
familiar with already just can't quite
see it let me help him what I done
I just multiplied through okay you can
multiply through by things so long as
they're not zero zero is what break
stuff okay but this this equation you
know what kind of equation is this it's
quadratic right it's a point right let
me just put everything on one side so
you can see it data right now it's a lot
of nice quadratic it doesn't play nice
with you right cuz nice ones you can
factorize all right you can look and say
oh I wanted number a parent up as it
adds up to this and multiplies to this
right would you like hold on right so
when you get when you meet a quadratic
and you can't factorize it what do you
do you use the formula we have for you
up the distance right
you'd say usually we say X right but you
could say Phi is equal to right now
what's the quadratic formula let's write
a minus B
see one okay should make good good now
by the way maybe remember where this all
comes from this is the result it comes
from completing the square
okay I can show you that another time
okay but the gunner that's what I have
to do I just have to know what a B and C
are a B and C space space fine is equal
to what's B B is negative 1 plus or
minus the square root oh okay so B
squared is negative 1 squared minus 4
watts off now what I can see there's a
fighting and this C 1 and minus 1 like
so all over 2a which is 2 times 1 okay
we've got a whole lot of negatives there
against up yeah right there
um what are a B and C a B and C they
they're the coefficients of this
quadratic equation in yes okay let's
cancel the negative shall we
double negative at the front plus or
minus 100
now hold on what on this is interesting
because this is quadratic and like any
quadratic you would expect it to have
two solutions
what's up sir wait a second
what some one of the solutions is one -
you final - and the other one is but yes
see I'm talking about links wait I get
is from I got a fringe geometry finds a
ratio it's it's it's all pause all of
this is positive right fine has to be
variable 0 yeah yeah that's exactly
right
if I put together all these positive
things you'll never get it negative out
the other side okay so therefore I can
say 1 minus root 2 Bible - that's not
alleged a itself construed 5 is what's
your 5
it's 2 points bla bla bla something
bigger than 1 so I care about
so therefore if this therefore it's that
one so what just happened we looked at
this and we said look it's a rectangles
okay let's look at all the rectangle
e-stop and used Pythagoras but then we
took the dive in and we just a little
bit just to not just see it from another
angle now you didn't look at this
evening quadratics but they they're
hiding